vous voulez bien deuxième sujet au
sommaire de cette émission de nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux a créé la
surprise ce week-end dans des
déclarations à libération où elle ouvre
la porte de façon assez claire à un
retour en france des jihadistes français
qui sont actuellement détenus en syrie
elle explique qu'elle aurait préféré
avoir une sorte de tribunal
international qui puisse ce qui aurait
pu juger ces terroristes en irak mais
que comme ce sera pas possible
elle ne voit pas d'autre solution que de
rapatrier ces gens c'est une mauvaise
idée
c'est une erreur considère manuel valls
l'ancien premier ministre
ecoutez-le c'était sur europe 1 il ya
deux jours c'est une erreur je pense que
ces hommes ces femmes qui ont commis des
faits atroces qui ont participé sans
doute pour beaucoup d'entre eux à la
guerre des actes de torture et des viols
doigt une manière ou d'une autre
cette revue est payé leurs actes là où
ils les ont commis sur les prisonniers
et les détenus dans nos dans l'eau dans
nos prisons beaucoup sortiront
d'ailleurs de ces terroristes dans peu
de temps dans quelques années sera un
défi supplémentaire pour la société
française
voilà c'est bien les arguments de ceux
qui s'opposent au retour de jihadistes
et lui dire qu'ils vont être incarcérés
et que les prisons françaises sont déjà
une sorte de deux d'école du jihadisme
je vous renvoie à ce propos un livre
passionnant celui du chercheur hugo me
seront sur le djihadisme français qui
explique que
les établissements pénitentiaires sont
des sortes de terreau pour ses idées il
ya 80 d'entretiens avec ddd condamné
incarcéré
il ya notamment ceux de ce témoignage de
youssef 27 ans qui dit je n'ai jamais
été autant épanouie idéologiquement et
mentalement quand prison ghisleni à elle
est votre point de vue est ce qu'il faut
rapatrier en france ces djihadistes qui
sont des français donc ils sont qui ont
pris les armes aux côtés de dh en
particulier en syrie
on est face à deux choix qui sont
mauvais mais je pense qu'il faut laisser
de laisser où ils sont parce que le
choix de ré patrie mon et le pire
pourquoi parce que le djihadisme c'est
un phénomène qui ressemble un petit pot
un nuage il faut des noyaux de
cristallisation autour desquels se
forment les nuages combler mire blanc
d'artigat s'étant frères musulmans
syriens qui s'installe en france qui
crée autour de lui un environnement où
il ya la famille mairat qui sont trois
ou quatre la famille klein qui sont 2
etc etc et donc on ré patrie quelqu'un
au delà de ce qui se passe dans les
prisons pédalant 7 8 novembre parce
qu'après ils sont ils raisonnent ségalar
aujourd'hui ils ont vingt cinq ans ils
vont en vendre 40 50 60 dans leurs
quartiers dans leur immeuble
s'il sera toujours ces mecs vénérables
anciens combattants qui dit des choses
autour de lui a toujours ce nébuleuse
con on n'a pas besoin de ça ici et si on
lit les livres excellent que vous venez
de montrer qu'ils méritent d'être
remontrer c'est exactement comme ça que
ça se passe
c'est exactement comme ça ça se passe et
donc de deux mauvais choix
le pire c'est de leur faire venir ici
qu'il croupisse là où ils sont qu'ils
créent les effets pervers là où ils sont
on sait mieux c'est battre contre contre
des organisations terroristes à
l'étrangère que de pondre qui
pourrissent tous les pentes tous les
paniers chez nous nos internautes sont
vraiment en ligne avec ce que vous venez
de dire puisque vous pouvez réagir en
direct sur twitter 85% donne raison à
manuel valls qui est opposé au retour
des djihadistes en france c'est à peu
près d'ailleurs les mêmes proportions
que quand on fait des sondages d'opinion
puisque l'aca n'est pas un sondage mais
l'expression des tours de main je ne
sais pas peut-être en tout cas on voit
que vous y être favorables chergui
mihaly voilà c'est pas le point de vue
de virgile c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
il faut accepter les djihadistes en
france considère thil et éviter la
surpopulation dans les prisons kurde
parce que c'est effectivement ce sont
les kurdes qui jusqu'à présent garde ces
djihadistes qui ont été arrêtés c'est
juste de la solidarité et babineau qui
est assez partagée et dire on parle pas
de dizaines de prisonniers mais de
centaines
il ne faut pas non plus laisser les
djihadistes s'évaporer ça c'est l'un des
arguments de nicole belloubet qui dit
mais si on ne les rapatrie pas en france
où ils seront en prison ils vont se
disperser dans la nature et ce sera
peut-être pire que mieux guillaume
demont jours qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi je pense qu'il ya
d'abord l'irak a dit qu il voulait plus
les garder et ne jugerai pas donc c'est
compliqué à gérer la deuxième chose
c'est que les kurdes et sailor ça leur
donne un levier sur nous assez important
les turcs les kurdes tous ceux qui les
ont laissé passé qui les gardent bas
c'est vrai quand il ouvre le robinet il
y en a quelques-uns qui s'en vont ça
nous fait peur et tu as raison donc je
pense que ça ne nous met dans une
situation indescriptiblement
inconfortable et je pense que ça
concerne 400 500 personnes à peu près
dans ces prisons aux kurdes 400 à 500
personnes qui sont eux-mêmes des
combattants déjà d'ici à leurs enfants
leurs familles et leurs femmes leurs
enfants petits qui ont vu ou pas des
événements enfin des incidents des
exactions et des violences donc il ya
plusieurs sujets à l'intérieur de ce
sujet dame et je dirais que moi on
m'appelle pour me dire mes enfants aux
mille
ont mis le feu à l'école je vais aller
rechercher février en fait pour moi un
passeport français
même si ça vous donne dans le fond un
plus ça de voir qu'un droit ce sont nos
ressortissants ils ont grandi chez nous
ils ont été élevés chez nous ils ont ce
statut de français killer qui leur
octroie cette protection ou sept en tout
cas cette statue qui fait qu'ils
relèvent de plus de notre juridiction à
nous aider lors qu'il revienne dans nos
prisons la seule question à se poser
c'est comment dans nos prisons on a des
moyens sept de leurs éventuels
rédemption puisqu'on a aboli la peine de
mort et qu'on refuse de dégâts voilà
donc en finir avec ces personnes et bat
mettons-les dans des endroits où enfin
c'est peut-être une idée fausse il
essaie de 5 6 ans quand liaison mais
seulement si les prisons sont bien fait
si on arrive à ré vraiment réhabiliter
quelque chose de fort mais non parce que
ces jours ça marche pas que selena dédié
10 comme dit votre recherche jarry là il
a fait un titre comme ça mais c'est
passé le sexe est devenu la prison le
lieu de la formation comme comme le dit
hugo michon mais en fait dans les faits
c'est sa seule question à se poser c'est
dans quel endroit en france on pourrait
accueillir ses 400 personnes ça énorme
400 personnes c'est pas comme si j'avais
une marée humaine de vingt mille
personnes et 1 400 personnes qu'on l'ait
vraiment qu'on les sorte d'une un entre
soi qui finalement ne fait que en effet
fructifier cette idéologie radicale et
voilà et donc je dirais que c'est c'est
le sujet à se poser avant de se demander
s'il faut ou non vers d'autres il faut
savoir est-ce qu'on a les moyens de leur
rédemption de les rapatrier de les aider
à sortir de ce cercle infernal
peut-être en créant à guantanamo à la
française se propose babineau même s'il
ajoute aussitôt que l'exemple américain
était une catastrophe
et puis nicole qui considère au
contraire qu'il faut surtout les déchoir
de leur nationalité française c'est
djihadistes comme le fait la belgique
entre autres votre point de vue arnaud
benedetti j'entends le point de vue du
rapatriement ceci dit moi je suis comme
fervent partisan de la responsabilité
individuelle ces gens là sont
responsables de leurs actes
et me semble-t-il tout à fait logique
qu'à un moment je donne et il en tire
les conséquences s'ils sont jugés bien
évidemment s'il songe et donc moi ça ne
me choque pas qu'ils soient jugés par
des tribunaux étrangers à partir du
moment où ils ont commis un certain
nombre d'actes qui sont des actes
atroces et des actes de guerre j'ai pas
souvenir que la france soit allé
récupérer les derniers oif nss qui se
battaient français il faut le signaler
qu'ils se battaient autour du booker
d'hitler on les a laissées aux mains des
russes ça s'imposait parce qu'il ne
faisait pas de problème à l'époque le
deuxième le deuxième souci c'est en
effet c'est finalement leur tour leur
tour ils vont se retrouver dans des
prisons françaises
on sait qu'il ya un processus aussi de
djihad isation dans ces prisons
aujourd'hui est ce que on a intérêt de
ramener des gens qui in fine est
apparaîtront au près disons des détenus
radicaliser comme in fine est dé sorte
de héros c'est une question là aussi
qu'il faut se poser ce risque est
important le troisième point c'est en
effet une fois qu'ils sont sortis c'est
lui risques qu'ils font courir
éventuellement parce que je crois pas
trop à la rédemption parce que
manifestement ils sont quand même dans
une idéologie qui est extrêmement disons
mortifère et où le combat qu'il mène est
un combat qui est le combat de leur vie
en l'occurrence et donc il peut y avoir
peut-être des cas individuels de
rédemption mais à mon sens ils seront
très marginaux c'est le problème de leur
sortie ensuite de prison et le dernier
point c'est que je suis absolument
convaincu mais tous les sondages le
montrent que l'opinion publique
aujourd'hui française et y
majoritairement hostile au retour des
djihadistes donc je ne suis pas sûr que
là aussi politiquement ça soit un
excellent point que de les faire revenir
au regard de la grande delà de la grande
frilosité de l'opinion publique quant à
ce sujet c'est pas mal penser aussi que
c'est à la fois dangereux politiquement
et surtout dangereux pour la sécurité de
notre sûrement dangereux mais moi je
trouve qu'il est bien gentil c'est
vraiment facile c'est vraiment facile de
le problème n'est pas tant
enfin si j'ai bien compris il est patent
c'est ce qu'a dit nicole belloubet il
n'ya pas tant de savoir s'il faut les
faire rentrer ou bien qu'il reste là bas
c'est que comme vous le dites
on est à peu près sûr qu'ils vont pas
être jugé en irak maintenant vu l'état
de désorganisation de l'irak même pas
être transférés en irak
donc à un moment donné ils vont sortir
alors après est-ce que le djihadiste
c'est prendre la ccss bouger je pense
que oui donc la question elle est plutôt
est ce qu'il faut les faire rentrer et
c'est de faire ce qu'on peut j'en sais
rien et éventuellement les jeux parce
que même pas sûr qu'on puisse les juger
en france avait un certain nombre qu'on
pourra pas juger ça m'a pas de preuve
donc de ce qu'ils ont fait ou bien ce
qu'il faut les laisser la nature et puis
je pense qu'ils sont assez futé pour
pour venir nous embêter quand même bon
la seule chose c'est que d'abord tous
les pays effectivement tous les pays
européens sont à peu près d'arenas que
nous le rappelait aussi dans ce problème
là et puis je vais vous dire un petit
truc qui m'a qui m'a amusé si on peut
dire que le sujet n'est pas amusant mais
sur ces problèmes de programme de
déradicalisation de bord et sont assez
récents donc on peut pas vraiment faire
de bilan le dernier date de il avait été
changée parce qu'il y avait un truc
collectif qui marchait pas il date d'à
peu près un an et à 110 personnes
aujourd'hui seulement qu'ils ont suivi
et alors mais c'est juste pour dire que
danemark appelle son programme de
déradicalisation exit remettre dans le
droit chemin
ce que je trouve assez clair --nous
l'appel recherche
il s'appelle rivère ive recherche et
intervention sur les violences
extrémistes
je trouve c'est assez clair sur votre
manière d'aborder les choses et sur la
manière de pas nommer les choses que
nous avons voilà c'était juste table m à
9 heures mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter du malheur au monde disait la
case du on va parler d'un autre sujet ou
là on nomme les choses c'est le sujet du
célibat des prêtres ainsi nos dressant
de l'église catholique consacré